In the beginning...
Gorgeous, gorgeous, gorgeous.
Oh!
..there were 12.
I can't believe that's
just happened to me.
They're not going to allow
me into Yorkshire ever again.
Now...there are three.
Right, calm down now.
(Good luck, guys.)
Good luck, guys.
'Winning Star Baker in the first week...'
No!
'..Jane got off to a flying start.'
Absolutely beautiful, yes.
Thank you.
'Her home-style baking
impressed Mary and Paul.'
That is first-rate.
This is a complete mess.
'Although timing often
wasn't on her side.'
Things didn't go to plan.
No, they didn't.
'The garden designer dug deep
to make it to the final.'
That fleur-de-lis is outstanding.
Thank you.
To be at the final is just amazing.
It feels really unreal, actually.
People say to you, "Oh, how've you been?
"What's happened this week?"
You go, "You know,
nothing, really, same old,"
and you want to go, "I'm in the final
"of The Great British Bake Off!"
And you can't.
Candice has won Star Baker three times.
Well done.
Her elaborate creations...
Wow, exceptional.
..went the extra mile...
It's like you, isn't it? You
like to do things over the top.
..and both impressed and
frustrated the judges.
Rein it in a little bit. Get
your baking absolutely spot-on.
But with bakes inspired by her family...
- The overall effect is beautiful.
- Yes!
..she's made it to the final.
There's been a lot of practice this week.
The other day, I did baking
for 12 hours, and I hurt a lot.
I'd really like to think I'd,
like, got really fit and toned
and everything from baking.
Definitely haven't.
Definitely struggling to
fit in clothes currently.
'Aerospace engineer Andrew...
Where are your schematics for this?
'..has been Mr Precision.'
The overall effect is
absolutely brilliant.
'Despite his meticulous methods...'
Guided rolling pin - gives me
uniform thickness of dough.
'..when it came to Star Baker...'
Well done, Tom.
'..for weeks, he was the bridesmaid...'
Benjamina.
'..never the bride.
'But dessert week onwards...'
They look gorgeous.
'..was a turning point.'
I've never seen a mechanised pie.
'At last he won Star Baker...'
The presentation is stunning.
'..and won it again in the semifinal.'
Coming in, I really
wanted to make the final.
That was my number one objective,
and then if I can win it...
That seemed like a
silly dream at the time,
but now that we're here,
I've got to darn well try.
Bakers, finalists!
Welcome to the tent. And the
final this year is being given...
..the royal treatment.
Between the four of us,
we already have a sponge sceptre
and several jellied orbs,
but Mary and Paul would
like to complete the set
by giving you the challenge of
making a filled meringue crown.
We're not talking some little
nimby-pimby tiny crown.
No, bakers, we want a family-sized crown
big enough for the whole royal family.
It must have three layers
of meringue, at least...
..and it must be dazzlingly decorated.
You've got three hours on this challenge.
- On your marks...
- Get set... - Bake!
Good luck.
Good luck, guys.
The nerves are a bit jangly.
I've dropped a bowl already.
It is the final.
We've been waiting for this,
and I think it's quite right we go royal.
After all, it is the
Queen's 90th birthday year.
This is the last signature chance,
so we've chosen meringue.
Now, they've struggled
with meringue in the past,
so I thought it was a good idea
to go back to the meringue again.
We've asked for a crown.
How they achieve that is up to them,
but what I am looking for -
it's got to taste good, look
good and be spectacular.
Three tiers of meringue can be
quite sweet and overwhelming,
so they've got to add a
little bit of tartness to it.
That can come from the fruit -
whether it's a curd, a compote,
that will balance out the
sweetness of the meringue.
I haven't any idea who's going to win.
It's an open field.
I'm looking forward to it.
Good morning, Jane.
- Good morning.
- Right, tell us all about your meringue crown.
My meringue crown is a red,
white and blue meringue crown
with strawberry and raspberry compote,
and then the next layer
is a blueberry compote,
and then the top is white flesh
nectarines with other fruits.
Jane's red, white and blue pavlova
is her husband Ray's favourite dessert.
She's hoping that sticking with her
tried and tested family favourite
will be a hit with Paul and Mary.
Now, you've kept it fairly
simple for the final.
I have kept it simple, but I want
it to be a good pavlova at the end.
Guys, simple is good, surely?
Well, it comes down to perfection.
When you go simple, we are
looking for the best flavours,
the best look with no failure.
No pressure, then!
All three bakers have opted
for a pavlova-style meringue.
I'm using muscovado
sugar as well as caster.
It gives it a more caramelly
flavour, which I quite like,
but can lead to
easier-collapsing meringues.
Can tend to crack slightly,
but flavour wins, right?
This is just caster sugar.
I want a nice, as white
as possible, meringue.
True to form for this regal signature...
It needs to be just right.
Just like Goldilocks.
..Candice is going a little further.
I am doing two different meringues.
One of them I'm adding
white caster sugar,
and the other one will
have golden caster sugar.
Her two different meringues will
make three tiers of pavlova,
filled with Prosecco-soaked strawberries,
mango curd, gold-dusted Physalis
and glittered pistachios.
Then there's a fourth tier,
inspired by the tiny
crown of Queen Victoria.
You've chosen to do quite a lot
of different things, actually.
- Yep.
- You've got to do it all in the time.
I have got to do it all in the time,
but I think once the meringues are in,
the bits in the middle I can fill.
As long as they've got their
cooking time and their cooling time,
so they're nice and crisp,
then it's just a case of building it up.
- All right, good luck.
- Thank you.
I thought I'd reined it in.
I didn't think I was going
complicated at all this week.
I've got three main
layers, three flavours,
one mini crown, a curd and some fruit.
Nothing.
So, I've increased the speed now
that all the sugar's been added,
and then I'm looking
for really solid peaks.
There's nowhere to hide if
the meringue goes wrong.
There will be no time to remake.
If it isn't beaten until
it's completely stiff...
Still soft.
..when piped, the meringue
will lose its shape...
..and then collapse as it's baked.
Suddenly feeling really nervous.
Oh, how can meringue do this to you, eh?
I'm just going freehand on my circle.
Whoops!
That's going to be my
meringue cross on top.
The next meringue is
going to have colour.
This is going to have pistachio on it.
So my Queen Victoria
crown will go on here.
I wanted to feature that cos I
loved that when I was younger.
You do need steady hands.
Just applying some gold lustre to
give it a nice vibrant royal look.
Good morning, Andrew. How are you?
Good morning, I'm very well, thank you.
Tell us about this meringue.
This is just a classic meringue
and I've used a 50-50 caster
sugar to muscovado composition.
- Yeah.
- I'm just going to pop them in the oven.
And you're confident about getting
it all finished and looking good?
I have had a couple of
slight meringue collapses,
so I'm a little nervous about
the structure at the end.
But hopefully my added
rings in the centre will...
- Give it support.
- Yeah.
Andrew's engineering
expertise will be fully tested
in his re-creation of
the Queen's Jubilee crown
in muscovado meringue.
It will contain a pecan praline centre
and layers of blackberry fool,
topped off with cassis jelly jewels.
Now, you've chosen a difficult meringue.
Muscovado sugar, being very moist,
and I notice that it is quite
runny now... I hope it holds.
My engineering credentials
are going to be tested.
They will be. Severely.
Right, going in. I'm leaving it in
there for an hour and ten minutes.
They're going to go in the oven
for about an hour and 20 minutes.
I'm baking mine for an hour
on a fairly low temperature.
About 130.
Now is the bit I can enjoy a bit more.
They're in the oven. I can't worry
about them, I can't change them.
It's in the hands of
chemistry and the gods.
The finalists need to spend every minute
that the meringues are in the oven
perfecting their fillings and toppings.
Now I get to make the jellied jewels.
I'm adding gelatine, some creme cassis.
I just love blackberries, so
I'm going for gold and purple.
It was inspired by the
Queen's coronation crown.
I have got some blueberries, a bit
of sugar, a bit of lemon juice,
a little bit of water.
I'm going to make a blueberry compote
and then a strawberry and
raspberry compote as well.
Nothing like British
fresh fruit, is there?
This is my pecan praline.
I'm hoping I've put this on
the right side of the paper.
This is mango curd.
As it's a special occasion,
this is Prosecco for my strawberries.
(Aah!)
There's two sides to the baking paper
and I've put it on the wrong one.
As you can see, it...
Facepalm.
45 minutes remain in the
final Signature Challenge.
The oven is turned off, so I'm
just waiting for them to cool down.
They've finished baking.
Technically now it's more
important to let them cool down
really, really slowly.
Sudden changes in temperature
could destroy the meringue...
I'm just on crack watch.
..and will make constructing
a crown impossible.
Two minutes. I'm just going
to hold my nerve. Two minutes.
I'm coming out. I'm going...
If you rush it, you open the
door of the oven and get them out
and you can hear them
going, "Ping! Ping! Ping!"
You can actually hear them cracking.
I might just put them back
in the open oven just to reduce
the temperature shock a bit.
- What are you listening for?
- I don't know.
Jane just said, "Can
you hear it crackling?"
So I thought I'd listen.
Eat me! Eat me!
This one is looking a little stronger.
Oh, gosh! My stomach just turned over.
The bottom one has cracked.
(Oh, look. They are amazing!)
You can't out-Candice Candice.
You've just got to be
happy with what you do.
Perfection is all I've got to hit today.
Bakers, here's the story.
You've got 15 minutes
on your crowning glory.
I'm sorry to be bore-y.
This is where you find out
if the meringues have stuck,
and try and keep smiling
if that's the case.
'The judges are looking for at least
three tiers of crowning glory.'
Oh, hello!
Oh, don't do that.
My cream has whipped up
nice and light, actually.
It is mascarpone, double
cream and vanilla.
OK.
It looks like we might
have got away with it.
I just need to start constructing.
- What's going on, my love?
- So, I'm going to...
try and stick this on
with a bit of caramel.
Carefully, carefully.
Blueberry compote. It
is a little bit runny,
but what I'm going to do is I'm
going to make a blueberry dam.
God, it's a delicate beast.
Praline to go in the middle.
These are my jewelled pistachios.
This is blackberry fool. I
want this to be slightly sharp.
There is a lot of sugar in the meringue,
so I don't want it to be too sweet.
My bottom is cracking. I can see it.
I'll just about have enough cream.
Whoops!
I'm just going to shine up my Physalis.
You want to make sure you get that right.
Five minutes, bakers.
Just five minutes left.
Oh, jelly. Jelly, jelly!
(He's putting it on the Queen.)
OK, bakers, that's it.
Time is up.
Coronation time, gang.
Paul and Mary are expecting
a spectacular meringue crown
with at least three tiers and
full of delicious fillings.
You've chosen a meringue
using muscovado sugar,
which is very difficult
to get definition.
If we look at the top here,
we haven't got a clear
definition of your icing pipe.
I'm going to take a slice.
You've got to keep it
very much on the head.
Yes.
Tell me, what's happening in the middle?
I put the pecan praline in there.
All the flavours go well.
The praline is very, very sweet
and it's slightly
overpowering everything.
Obviously meringue is sweet,
therefore, for me, the rest
needs to be a little bit sharp.
The fool hasn't got much flavour to it.
I think the meringue's gorgeous.
It's nice and soft inside.
You've got a nice chew.
The jelly, I like. It's
got a lot of flavour in it.
It has got more of a kick,
actually, than the fool has.
I don't like the praline in the
middle, but I love the effect.
OK.
I think it looks great.
I love the pipework. There's
a lot going on in there.
- Yeah.
- I was a bit worried about this little crown on the top,
how you were going to
get it off the moulds,
but you've managed to get it off OK.
It looks impressive,
and I love the way you've
got so many flavours there.
I didn't think you'd finish, but you did.
Oooft!
You can actually feel the texture
of the meringues all the way down.
- Oh!
- The way it's holding is quite impressive.
It's actually staying in one piece,
and what a piece of meringue that is!
Wow!
Your curd is lovely.
The meringue, it's got a
lovely softness in the middle.
There's so many textures in there,
and the flavours are quite sharp.
And you've got the nuts in there as
well, which adds something to it.
Yeah, I like that.
A handshake! Hollywood
handshake!
(Handshake!)
You've made, from
appearance point of view,
a first-rate meringue.
It's held all its shape perfectly.
I can't wait to get the texture
of that meringue, you know.
It does look very impressive.
- Yeah, it does.
- Oh, thank you.
Oh, the way that the
knife just falls through!
Look how solid it is at
the bottom there as well.
Perfect, isn't it?
The flavours go very well.
Your coulis is sharp, and do
you know what is really sharp?
The peach on top,
which is just what you
need with a pavlova.
Because it's so tall,
it's very difficult for it
to actually hold together
when you cut it.
Your description of a sort of
pavlova trifle is about right.
I sense... I knew... Oh, hello!
Oh, thank you!
Thank you.
Three layers of heaven.
- It's beautiful.
- Thank you very much indeed.
I'm absolutely delighted.
I got the handshake!
When Candice got her
handshake, I thought,
"I've never seen two handshakes.
"I've never seen two
handshakes. Not a chance."
And I got a handshake!
He's giving out handshakes willy-nilly.
But, no, Jane's did look spectacular.
First bake of final done
and I couldn't really have
got off to a better start,
which is amazing.
It was a bit of a kick in the teeth
to have, like, the double handshake.
I can deal with one.
Two is a bit, like...
Really, I need to come
first in the Technical.
Definitely at the back of
the pack at the moment.
Now, bakers, this is your
last ever Technical Challenge.
Any advice, Mary?
This bake will be very familiar,
but there are one or two
tricky things about it.
Wow, cryptic!
Now, off you both go to
your intimacy workshop.
Catch you later.
OK. Now, Mary would love you to make a...
Victoria sandwich with
jam and buttercream.
But there's a twist.
Lift that up, you'll see boxing gloves.
Put them on, then the Zorro mask,
then just tease the trousers down
and you're ready to go.
You've got an hour and a
half on your challenge.
- On your marks...
- Get set... - Bake!
OK.
We have absolutely no instructions.
Are you ready for this?
"Make a Victoria sandwich
using two 20cm tins
"filled with raspberry
jam and buttercream."
That's it.
Right.
So, Mary, you've chosen a classic
challenge for the last Technical.
Victoria sandwich.
We've given them no recipe, no method,
just two tins and the ingredients.
Now, you've judged quite
a few Victoria sandwiches
- in your time, I'm sure.
- I've never counted.
I mean, I've done village
shows, county shows, schools...
So I know exactly what it should be.
They can do it by the all-in-one method,
they can do it by the creaming method,
but it should look exactly
like that when it's finished.
Beautifully level, a very even rise,
pale golden all the way around,
and a beautiful texture inside.
It's going to be fascinating
to see how they cope with this.
I hope the bakers come up
with something that's good.
I think they will.
Unsalted butter, we've got salted butter.
We've got medium eggs,
we've got large eggs.
We've got... No idea what that is.
My ratios are 225g of self-raising flour,
butter, sugar, four large eggs...
I'm going to go for four large eggs.
Victoria sponge is all about
having exactly the same amount
of every ingredient.
I'm weighing the eggs
because it's the final
and weighing the eggs feels
like the right thing to do.
259g of everything.
So, 227 self-raising, butter and caster.
I always use golden caster sugar at home,
so I'm going to use
golden caster sugar here.
I'm going to go caster. I
don't want it to be too dark.
I'm going to do it exactly how
I do it at home, all in one.
I'm going to do an all-in-one method,
which is a Mary favourite, I think.
I'm going to cream the
butter and sugar first.
I'm going to go for the creamy method.
I don't actually make a
lot of Victoria sponges.
I'm relying on memory.
We should know how to do
it, but if it goes wrong,
we're going to use look pretty daft.
Have I put everything in
that I should have done?
Eggs might help.
How are you, love? How's the final going?
I could use with this one
being a good one, to be honest.
To be out of the handshake
club was a little demoralising.
- Matey!
- I know, the double handshake.
But the handshake
doesn't mean everything.
You have come back from things
before, Andrew, haven't you?
I have, but this isn't about coming back,
this is about ending up on top, isn't it?
(Oh, Andrew, that's fighting talk!)
I mean, you've got to be open
at this stage, haven't you?
- Everyone wants to win.
- Everyone. - Everyone in this tent.
Or die trying!
Just to be extra anorak-like,
I'm going to make sure I weigh
how much batter goes into each.
Slightly larger tins than I
use at home, but that's fine.
Just whack in some more mix.
It is important that it is level.
If it doesn't go right,
then I'm in big trouble.
I'm going in!
I should have 456 in each
if I've done that correctly,
which I hope I have.
There we go. 180 for 15 minutes,
but I think it will be more like 20, 25.
I've put it on 180 for 20
minutes to start off with.
I just really want to
get it in the oven now
cos I'm very behind the other two.
I'm going to go in with that.
Mid-shelf.
Start with 20, and then
I'll keep an eye on them.
I'm nervous about this,
because a tiny imperfection in a cake
could mean last in the Technical.
It's got to be right. Got to be right.
I am just going to get my jam on.
I'm going for half the quantity
of sugar to raspberries.
- Is it?
- I'm using 50-50.
Just the way I make it at home.
I've gone for 350g of
raspberries and 150g of sugar.
I never use buttercream at home.
A drop more milk in there.
You don't want it to be too thick.
In my experience, adding
it a spoonful at a time
gives a smoother buttercream.
I've tried it all-in-one before,
but it tends to go a bit grainy.
It could be the smallest
thing today that clinches it.
I need this.
I really need this.
Bakers, just half an hour till
I have your cake and eat it.
Mary is going to be looking
for a nice golden colour.
Maybe a little rise,
but more or less flat.
A bit dark on top.
(Mine are flatter than
Candice's, though.)
Relatively happy. They're
the right colour, so...
Candice's look good and Andrew's
look really nice over there as well.
(Oh, it's tense, this, isn't it?)
My jam is not as firm
as I'd like it to be.
Another 15 minutes in the
fridge will probably help.
All going for seedless over there.
This is my interpretation.
It's either going to work, or it's not.
You have five minutes left on your
last-ever Technical Challenge.
It is the final, so I'm going
to pipe the buttercream in.
We're going to end up
doing the very same look.
It means there'll be
more direct comparisons.
If I'm honest, being
directly compared to Jane
is quite intimidating.
I think that looks yummy.
Right, you magnificent
spongers, time is up.
Could you bring them up to
the gingham table, please?
Mary and Paul are looking for
a perfect Victoria sandwich
with a light sponge filled with
raspberry jam and buttercream icing.
OK, shall we start with this one, Mary?
This one looks quite dark, actually.
It looks a bit too dark, and this
jam doesn't look as though it's set.
You can see it dripping
down the side there.
It's really a jelly rather than a jam,
because the pips have been taken out.
The actual sandwich -
the structure looks good.
It's a good, even texture throughout.
I think the Victoria
sandwich tastes good,
but that buttercream is quite grainy.
Right, moving on. This has
a nice texture on this one.
It's quite even. I like
the colour on this as well.
I like the buttercream in there.
- It's quite neat.
- Looks a very good jam there.
It's a good thing I like
a Victoria sandwich.
You notice what a big piece
I'm taking of each one!
It's buttery, it's got good flavour.
- That's a good Victoria sandwich, that, it tastes good.
- Mmm.
Moving on to the last one, Mary.
It's a little bit on the dark side
and it has a very large rise to it.
I think it's got a lot
of mixture in there.
- A lot of mixture.
- It's considerably bigger.
The buttercream is a
bit on the soft side.
The jam is quite thick, actually.
They have cooked it through,
and it is a good flavour.
OK. This is going to be tricky.
But which finalist has baked
a technically perfect Victoria sandwich?
This has been a very
difficult task for us.
We've been backwards and forwards.
It was very close between two and
three, I'll tell you that much.
In third place is this one.
There was more mixture in there
than I would have expected,
and the jam itself was
a little bit gluey.
And the buttercream was very soft.
In second place is this one.
The flavour of your jam was
better, marginally, than Jane's.
The buttercream, however,
was a little bit grainy.
But the overall flavour of the
sponge was just a little bit better.
Thank you.
And in first place is this one.
Well done, Andrew.
We have an even bake, a
nice pale, golden colour.
We've got a good jam and a
lovely, smooth buttercream.
Thank you.
Well done, well done.
To stand a chance at all,
I needed to come first.
And, yeah, really pleasantly surprised.
Two is all right. I thought
I was going to be third.
I do think, genuinely, we are
all going into it fairly even,
and that's quite nice.
I think the trophy is still
very much up for grabs.
There's just one challenge remaining
in the 2016 Great British Bake Off.
In just a few hours, at
a very special picnic,
either Candice, Jane or Andrew
will be crowned this year's winner.
They're making an awful lot of
stuff in their Showstopper, Mary.
An unbelievable amount.
I mean, it's one of the
most exciting Showstoppers
we've ever had.
I know it's very difficult
judge between just three of them
being so close. Let's cut to the chase.
Candice and Jane are very,
very close in the Signature.
Candice went really
overboard with the meringue.
I think it worked, as well.
Likewise, Jane did the perfect pavlova.
And then it all changed again.
Andrew didn't have such a good Signature,
but he came top in Technical.
It was a very good Victoria sandwich.
Paul gave the double Hollywood handshake
to the ladies in the tent.
He gave a single handshake.
There was a single handshake to Candice.
And there was a full double for Jane.
- The Roman clasp?
- I've never...
We've never seen the Roman clasp
before, I don't think, from Paul.
Is this telling us something
about where they're standing
in the pecking order?
- No.
- Right. I'm glad we started with that, then! - Just checking!
Bakers, welcome to your
final Showstopper Challenge.
Paul and Mary would very much like you
to make a picnic fit for Her Majesty.
What we would like you to make is
one chocolate celebration cake,
which Her Majesty apparently loves.
12 puff-pastry sausage rolls,
12 mini quiches,
12 savoury scones,
and 12 fruit and custard tarts.
That's 49 things altogether each.
You've got 20 minutes. On your marks...
You've got five hours.
- On your marks...
- Get set...
- Good luck, and bake.
- Bake!
Creating a whole range of bakes
for a picnic fit for the Queen...
..is the biggest-ever final
challenge in Bake Off history.
49 little things, all in five hours.
Easy peasy(!)
Keep it together, Andrew...
Five hours seems an awful lot,
but if they don't get
their planning right,
they won't finish on time.
This is batch baking and then some.
All the elements of a picnic
that you can think of.
Every one of those bakes
should be good enough
to put in front of the Queen.
Each item's got to be consistent.
We want a good finish as
well as good flavours.
I'm expecting perfection.
Pastry...
I'm doing my pastries first
so I can get them chilling.
I've got my spreadsheet, which...
I've got every five minutes planned
so I know exactly where I am.
I haven't worked out
timings properly on this,
but I think it should be...
I think it should be...
I think it should be fine.
I know the order, I
know I can get it done.
Going to do it.
- Hello, Candice.
- Good morning.
Right. What's going in your hamper, then?
I am doing a chocolate orange
and orange cardamom cake,
then I am doing sausage rolls -
bacon, mushroom, black
pudding. Little piggies,
so it'll have a little
nose, peppercorn eyes,
with crackling curly tails.
To complete her picnic,
Candice is also making
Manchego and olive scones,
salmon and asparagus quiches
and rhubarb and custard tarts,
all fit for not just a queen,
but pearly kings and queens.
What makes it special for
pearly kings and queens?
It's just a nod to where me
and my dad are from, really.
- Ah, right.
- Cockney, Mary, Cockney. - Cockney.
Candice's journey to the Bake
Off began when she was four,
when her nan, Margaret,
started teaching her to bake.
You always used to like
to wear Nan's glasses.
- Come to that, you used to put Nan's shoes on as well.
- Yep.
My mum was always baking, so Candice
wanted to be in on the action.
I'm so pleased Candice has
achieved this for herself.
I don't think there's any words
that can express how proud we are
as a family.
Candice will go hell for leather
to get whatever she wants.
I'm extremely proud of Candice.
Regardless if she wins
or whether she loses,
she'll always be a winner in
my eyes and she's my daughter.
This is my puff pastry
for my sausage rolls.
I'm going to do my first turn.
I used to hate making puff,
but I do quite enjoy it now.
It's important to keep it cold
just cos you don't want
the butter to melt.
If it softens up, it means you
won't get those nice, puffy layers.
The sooner the bakers
can prepare the pastry
for their sausage rolls and quiches...
(Right, next - next, next, next...)
Get that in the fridge.
Half an hour gone already.
What am I doing now? I don't know.
..the sooner they can begin their
show-stopping chocolate cake.
I'm just liquefying my coconut oil.
So rather than using
butter, I'm using oil.
It just makes it nice and moist.
I like adding ground almonds. I
like what it does to the texture
and it just keeps it a
little bit more moist.
My chocolate cake is my
gran's chocolate cake.
It's kind of our
definitive family recipe.
There is a lot riding on this cake,
so...hopefully, I'll do it justice.
Andrew's picnic of family favourites
will also include smoked
Cheddar and paprika scones,
sausage and chorizo jam rolls,
sweet potato, goat's cheese
and caramelised onion quiches
and strawberry and pistachio tarts.
- I call you "the precision baker".
- Right, OK.
It's all about timing. You've...
Oh, right, you've got
an Excel spreadsheet
- to tell you exactly what's going on.
- Yes, I do.
Minute by minute. We're
wasting time right now.
I'm five minutes behind.
That's every five minutes is planned
so I'm just dashing to the...
Yeah, it says here, actually, that...
Yeah, 9.05, "dash to
fridge". He's on time.
Always a high-flier,
Andrew first discovered
his love of engineering
through his love of cake.
Andrew's always rather
liked chocolate cake
and things and he wanted
to be able to make them.
Andrew has always been very passionate
about anything he's tackled
and Bake Off is no different.
He's been working full-time
and practising to one
o'clock in the morning.
He didn't actually go
to his own graduation.
We went and saw all his friends graduate.
He was baking.
If Andrew takes on any challenge,
he's always put 100% into it.
He's an achiever,
and the success he's had
so far has blown us away.
I absolutely think
Andrew deserves to win.
He's put so much hard work into it
and I hope he does cos
I love him to bits.
He'll hate me saying that!
I'm happy with the
consistency of the cakes.
They've gone in for 15 minutes at 180.
Just making my orange sponge.
This is cardamom and orange
and then I will cover it in an
orange cardamom syrup as well.
Chocolate cake's in the oven.
I've got my puff pastry in the fridge.
I'm just doing sweet
pastry for my fruit tarts.
I mean for this sweet
pastry to be nice and thin,
so about two millimetres.
I want it to be really crisp.
I want Paul to love it.
I don't want to see a
soggy bottom in sight.
I have no idea whether
I'm on schedule or not.
I just have great belief that
if I just keep going today,
if I keep going, it'll all be fine.
Jane's sweetcrust pastry tarts
will be filled with red fruits
and elderflower creme patissiere.
Her picnic will also feature
more of her family's favourites -
butternut squash and Parmesan scones,
apple and thyme sausage rolls,
salmon and dill quiches
and, for her four-tiered chocolate cake,
she's determined to succeed
with a decorative touch
that let her down during botanical week.
It's going to have a
white-chocolate lacy wrap and...
- A collar? You're putting a collar round it?
- Yeah.
- Another collar?
- I know, but it's going to be good this time.
- Victorian lacy collar.
- It's going to be good this time!
Jane has always worked
hard to create great bakes
for her family and friends.
But since the competition,
she's gone to new extremes.
Mum hasn't slept much
for the last 12 weeks.
I'll come down in the morning,
she's there, furiously baking,
has been awake since five
o'clock in the morning,
there's flour everywhere.
Already, she's made three
different sets of Danish pastries,
a wedding cake, a loaf of bread...
Yeah, she's been a bit obsessed.
Can you believe you're in the final?
I don't actually believe
I'm in that tent.
Mum's amazing at juggling everything.
She's managed to do
everything for Bake Off,
she's running her own business.
I don't know how she's done it all.
She's always put other people first
and this is the first thing
she's done purely for herself.
I really am very proud of you.
I know everybody thinks it, but
I think I've got the best mum.
Right, the moment of
truth. How's this pastry?
These are my sweet ones.
The pastry has caught on the edges.
"12.02, Sue comes in
and asks inane questions
"about what are you doing" -
what are you doing, Andrew?
I can always trust you
to be on schedule, Sue.
It's lovely.
Everything is important
in the Showstopper.
Absolutely everything.
Right, here we go.
Scones, actually.
Have I put everything in?
Squash, salt and pepper.
Pepper? No, no pepper.
This is my mum and gran's scone recipe,
quite traditional Irish thing,
kind of a soda bread method.
So I'm mixing my flour,
bicarb, some paprika,
buttermilk and some smoked Cheddar.
Handling it as little as possible
is the secret to good scones.
The temptation is to roll it out too far.
Quite a wet dough, so
it's sticking a bit.
Two-and-a-half hours remaining.
This is my creme patissiere,
which is going to go in my
fruit and custard tarts.
Not sure what the other bakers are doing.
I think they're making
their sausage rolls,
which is what I SHOULD be doing.
With 49 bakes to complete
and only one oven...
I'm going to assemble my
whole sausage roll in one.
Then I can get exactly
the same size piggies.
..time management has never
been harder or more important.
Puff's looking all right.
Yeah, puff's looking...
Puff's looking OK.
The amount of multitasking
required here is mind-blowing.
If I didn't have a plan
right now, I'd be flapping.
Ah!
I am going faster and faster.
I've got so many timers,
I'm not sure what the
timers are for, now.
We are steaming through.
Some of these poor piggies
might be a little cross-eyed.
Give them another...minute or two.
They really haven't risen at all.
Outside the tent, the contestants'
friends and family have arrived,
along with a few familiar faces.
I was quite anxious coming here.
Gingerbread falling down,
that was my last experience.
But no, it's really nice,
it's lovely seeing all the bakers again.
It's been really special.
It's really funny being back.
Of course I'd love to be
in the tent right now.
Great to be here, would
LOVE to be in there.
Oh, my gosh, who's going to
win it? Who's going to win it?
Don't ask me that question.
Candice.
She plans well, she's impeccable,
and she is so focused.
I've been backing Jane since week one.
I want Andrew to win...
..but it'll be a tough call,
cos the girls have
been very, very strong.
You know, Candice has been
Star Baker so many times
and Andrew and Jane have both
been so consistent - oh...!
I think I'm going to have to say Jane.
OK, finalists, you've got an
hour left of your Showstoppers.
One hour left.
Right, calm down, now.
I have got my collar and the
decoration to do on this.
I've got assembly of
the fruit tarts to do.
I've still got to bake my quiches.
So, um...quite a lot to get done, really.
I'm just melting my chocolate
for my chocolate icing
and just waiting for my
sausage rolls to cook.
I'm ashamed of myself for
not measuring out the pastry.
But got to get these
sausage rolls finished,
so...screw the measurements.
Is that pastry too thick?
I don't know.
Asparagus going into the
coffin there, lovely.
Just left it a little
bit too long in the oven.
I'm going to put some foil over the top.
Should hopefully stop
them browning too much.
OK, picnickers, you don't want
to keep a good wasp waiting.
You've got half an hour
to finish, half an hour.
I'm going to have to do
the chocolate collar now.
It's a very simple and easy
chocolate collar this time.
Got to try and chill that somehow.
Are you all right, Jane?
I'm fine. Yeah, yeah, yeah, fine.
OK. I've caught the edges of these.
So this is my sugar glaze.
It just makes it look
shiny and nice, really.
Right. One, two, three...
You can't leave it in there very long,
otherwise it won't be flexible at all.
One, two, three, four...
Those need at least an extra five.
Those are going to come out very hot.
Oh, stick, damn you, stick!
- (That's good.)
- Ooh, look at the rise on those!
OK, ladies and gent, I
have no wish to HAMPER you,
but you have five minutes left
on your final Showstoppers.
Ah...!
It's not doing it! It's not coming off!
I have a minor disaster here.
My chocolate collar,
I over...over-chilled it.
And it doesn't want to come off.
I don't quite know what
I'm going to do about that.
OK, little piggies need to
put things in the hamper,
little piggies need to
stop in two minutes.
These are the sausage rules.
My collar is not to be. What a pity.
Oh, if in doubt, throw some
glitter at it, I always say.
OK, bakers, five hours is up.
You can do no more.
- You've finished!
- Wahey, well done!
Oh, well done, guys, well done!
My God.
That was mad.
I honestly don't know if
I've done enough to win.
It'll all come down to the
quality of the pastry and flavours
and you can't tell that
from looking at them.
I will always see the negatives,
always see the bits I don't like,
always think everybody
else's is better, but...
...I have just...I have given it...
I've given everything.
I think I could cry.
I think it's just the
emotion of finishing
and not doing it again.
I think that's really sad.
I'll really miss it.
I've loved every minute.
I'm going to just wipe my eyes now.
Cos I'm not going to cry.
But it's been great.
Jane, do you want a hand
with your hamper goods?
I'm sure the Queen would love
this colourful selection,
and it does look right royal and regal.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
So let's start with the sausage roll.
You've got some issues with
raw pastry inside here.
Oh, is it?
- You see the layers?
- Oh, yes.
It hasn't baked all the way through.
- But the flavour... Tastes delicious.
- Thank you.
This is the tart.
Pale, but baked.
Nice and crispy.
It looks absolutely cram-jam
full of salmon and prawn.
Mmm. It's very, very good.
Right - scone.
To me, with my eyes shut,
it tastes like a rather
good cheese scone.
I don't actually taste
the butternut squash.
Which is a shame. It
would've been nice to get
something with a little
bit more kick in it.
These tarts - the decoration
on the top is so pretty,
you couldn't resist picking those up.
You've managed to keep that
pastry beautifully crisp.
The creme pat has held and none
of it is dripping down the side.
The flavour's good.
Right. We'll move on to your cake.
It isn't what you planned, your
band, but you didn't panic.
You've done it.
Now, that's a lovely surprise
in the middle, there.
- Great chocolate cake.
- Thank you.
- Tastes beautiful. It's light...
- Thank you. - Soft...
And then with that cream in the middle,
with the kick from the cherries...
That's beautiful. It's a
shame about the collar.
Andrew.
It is beautifully displayed.
Very meticulous, just like you.
Everything we've seen
has been very calculated
and beautifully presented.
Right, we'll start with the sausage roll.
Let's have a quick cut.
It's not done here.
Yeah.
The taste of that sausage is fantastic.
Beautiful sausages,
but it's such a thick layer
of undercooked pastry.
I think I'd be leaving that.
Scone.
I think the colour and the
look of them is most exciting,
but the flavour just isn't there.
I'm trying to find the
cheese. I've got the paprika.
I'm not getting it at all.
Let's try the quiche.
Nice colour. It's nice and neat
all the way round, as well.
Looks like it's been
professionally blocked.
- Crispy.
- That's the right thickness of pastry.
The flavour of that is delicious.
OK.
However, you probably worked that
pastry a little bit too much.
That should just fall apart.
Let's try the strawberry tart.
Now, obviously, straightaway,
there is an issue with this.
- Yeah.
- I daren't even lift it.
I know it's going to be soggy underneath.
Well, it's basically raw underneath
because everything's soaked
in to that blind-baked pastry.
Actually, it tastes good.
I think the problem is, when
you put the sugar syrup on it,
it's soaked into the side of the pastry
and so the whole thing just collapsed.
OK. Let's have a look at this cake.
- Those shards are beautiful on top.
- Cuts great.
You said this was your grandma's recipe?
Yes.
That's a great cake.
That's a really nice cake.
She'll be very pleased to hear that.
The ganache keeps it moist.
It's a very, very good chocolate cake.
I think that's the
star piece in all this.
- I'd have the cake any day.
- OK.
Thank you.
It looks an exciting
hamper. Lots of colour.
I love your little piggies looking at me.
I'm dying to get into them.
- That's its mouth, I take it?
- Yeah.
- Nose, eyes...
- Yeah. - Yeah, OK. - And its little crispy tail.
Love crackling. Right...
Mmm...
That's a good puff pastry.
Nice flaky layers.
Unusual, with the black pudding.
I think they're great. I
think the flavour's fantastic.
And you've got beautiful layers.
- Thank you.
- OK. Shall we move on to the quiche?
Ooh, yeah. Crispy all
the way. Sides, bottom...
It's full, that, Mary, isn't it?
What I like is it's not all
sort of custardy filling.
We've got lots of salmon in here.
That's a good quiche. And it tastes good.
- Thank you.
- And the pastry's in nice layers.
It is. It's well baked.
Right, scone.
Nice colour on the top, nice size.
I can't taste the cheese.
- OK.
- Manchego's strong.
The problem is, olives are SO strong.
- I can taste the olive but I didn't get the cheese.
- OK.
Let's look at these
raspberry and rhubarb tarts.
They look attractive, and nice
to do it in a brioche tin,
rather than the conventional tin.
That's a good custard.
- Thank you.
- Rhubarb, you're very brave to put it in,
because there's so much moisture,
and in no way is that
soaking into the pastry,
the pastry is still crisp.
- It's a little over-baked.
- Yeah.
But the whole flavour is very, very good.
Let's try the chocolate.
That's a lovely cake.
The oil works well in it,
and the flavour of the orange
comes through beautifully as well.
Delicious orange.
You've got the right amount of ganache,
and I like the finish, as well.
I think that would be a great
cake to take on a picnic.
- Thank you very much.
- No, thank you. Thank you very much.
It's you two.
- No, no.
- It is!
As Candice, Andrew and Jane
join their family and friends...
..Mary and Paul have a
huge decision to make.
Well, this was an absolute
humdinger of a Showstopper.
The standard was exceptionally high.
Andrew's chocolate cake
was out of this world.
It had a beautiful texture, flavour.
But the fruit tart -
it was falling apart.
And the scones - no flavour.
Then you have Candice, who
is this very creative baker.
Everything packed with flavour.
Now, when you look at the actual quiche,
she put loads and loads
of salmon in there,
but it did taste extremely good.
Her sausage rolls...
I've had many sausage rolls in my time.
- I bet you have.
- And to make a little pig out of one...
They were different, and
the pastry was good, too.
- It's a sensational cake, isn't it?
- That orange!
And it was so soft inside. Great cake.
I like Jane because she
is a true family cook.
Her prawn quiche was
absolutely delicious.
I thought the fruit tart tasted great.
The sausage roll was slightly underdone.
Paul and Mary, the big
question is...who's won?
I've sort of made up my mind.
I've had a thought myself,
but I want to confirm it with Paul.
That seems reasonable, bearing
in mind you're the judges.
We shall leave now.
Finalists, what
incredible bakers you are!
Would the three of you step up, please?
- MEL:
- Oh, Jane... Jane's gone!
Jane, Andrew, Candice,
Mary and Paul have decided,
after a lot of deliberation,
that the winner of The
Great British Bake Off 2016
is...
..Candice!
- Well done!
- Well done, Candice!
Well done!
Well done, sweetheart.
Never, ever, ever thought
I'd ever even get on this,
and I'm standing here now with
this, and they said my name,
and that means more to me
than I think anyone
will ever, ever realise.
It really, really does.
Well deserved!
Her determination and passion...
She really has excelled.
Had wonderful flavours, and
everything always looked gorgeous.
Candice is very much all or nothing.
When you look back on some of her bakes,
they've been beautiful.
When she nails it, she's one of the best.
Come over!
Oh, my God!
Candice has been fantastic throughout.
'I'm chuffed to bits for her.'
You deserve it, Candice. Well, well done.
Of course I'm a little
disappointed, but actually,
to be able to walk out there at the
end with the hamper, see everyone...
Yeah, it's really special.
Oh, you star! Well done!
'The best baker today won.
I'm really happy for her.
'Week after week, Candice
has got better and better.'
I predicted it!
So my first prediction of
the series has come true...
dammit!
Em... I saw, and I wished,
and I hoped it was OK,
but you just don't know.
Jane and Andrew are so good, so good.
She's done so well. She's
been an absolute star.
I did it! I'm good.
I'm good enough.
I honestly...
I don't know what to say.
Thank you. Like...
Oh, my God! What an opportunity.
Amazing! I don't know what else to say.
- She did smash it.